عنطريق من الشمال التي الذي يمكن وصفه
بالجبهه الملتهبه هذا اليوم وفي تفاصيل
المشهد يمكن ان نتحدث عن ما اصدرته وما
اعلنته كتائب القسام في الجبهه الشماليه
وتحديدا نحن نتحدث عن هذا المحور محور
التفاح والدرج حيث اعلنت كتائب القسام عن
استهداف ثمان دبابات من نوع ميركافا وذلك
على محور التفاح والدرج كما اعلن ايضا
اعلنت القسام ايضا عن استهداف قوه راجله
هنا على مستوى محور التفاح اذا هذا المحور
الذي نتحدث عنه هو الذي اعلنت كتائب
القسام امس عن استهداف ناقله جند واعلنت
عن قتل عشره جنود وذلك من المسافه الصفر
على مستوى هذا المحور لكن حينما نتحدث عن
محور التفاح والدرج لابد ان نشير ايضا الى
الصور التي نشرتها الجزيره و بثتها
الجزيره واعلنتها القسام عن عمليات
استهداف واشتباكات من المصف صفر على اكثر
من محور هنا في التفاح والدرج ولكن ايضا
على مستوى
محاور محاور الشعف وايضا جبل الريس اذا
هذه هي المحاور الاربعه للاشتباك على
مستوى شمال قطاع شمال مدينه غزه لكن لو
ذهبنا الى تفاصيل المشهد و نتحرك نوعا ما
الى الشمال الغربي وتحديدا الى الشيخ
رضوان حيث اعلنت ايضا كتائب القسام عن
استهداف قوه راجله هنا واشتباكات من
المسافه الصفر واعلنت على ان هذه
الاشتباكات اوقعت نحو 20 جنديا بين قتيل
وجريح على مستوى محور الشيخ رضوان اللافت
اليوم هو هذه التطورات هنا في الشيخ عجلين
وحينما نشير الى الشيخ عجلين نحن نتحدث عن
الجبهه الغربيه من مدينه غزه حيث كانت
القسام اعلنت ايضا استهداف قوه متحصنه في
احد المبادي هنا في منطقه الشيخ عجلين